Bogg it's a fairly uneventful vlog
babban gonna have to figure out some
random [ __ ] right now which we will I'll
come up with some crazy rant but first
[Music]
hey guys good morning here in Houston
big ups congrats to the Astros big
championship what up little Lou full day
with clients you know we might bunch of
phone calls all internal Vayner
vaynermedia stuff show Jeff real quick
he hates it Jeff Nicholson are
incredible cheap media officer and I got
a lot of work done on the plate out here
for a 6 a.m. play that was pretty epic I
actually think the airplay actually vlog
Airport hack like I think more people
should take flights just to have
meetings than and leave like sometimes
it's that's all I possibly will do a
much more on the way back great holiday
weekend life is good
super pumped how well the permission
video is doing what permission are you
looking for I'm just so tired of you
know so many people are using me right
now to give them permission to do stuff
and it is my literally my literally
greatest feeling of my life if you
haven't seen it check it out very fired
up about today's cyber monday I know you
guys are seeing us Wednesday or Tuesday
I know what you guys are doing but cyber
monday offer on my new book crushing
it's gonna be phenomenal big cyber
monday deal going on today if you're
planning on buying crushing it my book
today is the day to do it I'm doing a
5/5 books get
into a contest five of you are getting
five where you are getting dinner with
me in New York City and just a lot of
themes right you know you saw cyber
monday and well I'm already assuming it
you know Black Friday and I assume today
on Cyber Monday just incredible dominant
maneuvering to retail happening online
and communication and your media
consumption patterns you know the
internet is eating up the world and that
you need to be on the right side of that
history working on oh three the speaker
launched these just a little bit of an
update working on a couple secret
projects and I can't tell you about and
just see them a day in the life of CEO
of a 800 person holding company today I
got some pure Wow stuff for the gallery
under the banner X world tons of
vaynermedia stuff just unlimited
vaynermedia stuff more about our
capability of what partner we bring in
and above the line make a quick phone
call to my dad and Brandon about Wine
Library stuff as they go into their
course season and also the white label
Herald and the and the Robert Craig and
the conv Ali I would go hard at that
just trying to up my game a lot a lot of
engagement on Instagram lately
Gavin's excited about all these hundred
thousand like Plus posts you guys look
like the Beatles the [ __ ] Beatles are
walking by anyway
I gotta go big meeting here in Houston
that's what I'm here for Babbage here
the ABI n
better than Dirac slightly worse than
Iris
all right I gotta go
[Music]
what's our one good tip you can give to
a young entrepreneur that that's trying
to grow his business farther on the
trainings are I'm trading side
I think it's content man we've got to
get out there you got to get people here
know who you are is it so they asked for
you is it
I think Instagram is ridiculous like how
often are you posted on Instagram
honestly honestly of myself for just
about a knowledge and generalities
information information you know you
looking good or maybe like posts on
Instagram on your Instagram account I go
to four four times a day and this
content or workout videos information
and what do you give them you know and
listen a good shot of you looking good
for them
but like more about them this video
about hashtags like really being smart
about has two hashtags like when you
post you need to post the first comment
needs to have 20 30 hashtags good
already saved now the next thing you got
to go you got to search hashtags like
Fitness things of that nature in your
radius so within a 20-mile radius of
this place let me show you we show you
so like literally you go into here and
you type in Fitness right and you go
into the tags right and you get that
okay right and now you need to like look
at people's stuff really consume it and
then leave a comment like yo bro that's
doing it right guys you need to become
part of the community not just pushing
out if you go hard four times a day
[ __ ] for them you go into 90 accounts a
day and leave your [ __ ] you know that's
you laying in bed in the morning or like
[ __ ] right now you're a little early
yeah exactly grab a coffee or whatever
you do and like you do that consider
honestly as I've gotten my fitness up in
the last couple years it's the same [ __ ]
you know about fitness
there's no shortcut there's no shortcut
and there's no steroids in this you know
there's no shortcut it's just [ __ ]
everyday eating like you know some
people like oh it's happening you're not
eating right or you're not you like it's
like I've all of a sudden finally
figured out how to use my
that's so much shoulders aren't hurting
and I'm finally starting to built you
know it's that discipline go into the
community it makes me man
yeah sure of course good I greatly
appreciate it we should well brother you
take care have a great holiday here's a
here's Justine and and Mark Evans they
are now here so now we are going to go
and attack YouTube YouTube YouTube I
love you guys please subscribe if you
haven't
would mean the world to me and I
appreciate all your comments right a
bunch of them over Thanksgiving enjoy
the [ __ ] out of it on my way to Equinox
for a shower cuz that's how I do it
Texans fan and and let's go fog is a
fairly uneventful vlog babban we're
gonna have to figure out some random
[ __ ] right now which we will I'll come
up with some crazy rant but first your
favorite moment vlog one of the great
things about this vlog is the memes
right like the fake or is it rivalry
between babban and d-roc but the best
meme no question is the incredible
nature of the greatest superhero we've
ever seen really like really the
greatest super I mean listen I'm a big
fan of Batman like I understand
spider-man and Superman and Thor's like
intrigued and amazing abs and biceps but
has there ever been a superhero more
exciting for 2018 entrepreneurs
the one and only
one of the great and I mean great
entrepreneurs of this generation hustle
coming out of all parts of his body and
that's just how we do it we made it baby
we made it baby mentality g5
[ __ ] airplane big dick baby
pleasure man
pleasure inter port Gary now you know
why he's such a great superhero because
he deals with content of all kinds at
all times and never wavers baby airport
Gary that was incredible
nice knowing that this is gonna be a
Content thin episode I think it's super
important to hang out a little rant give
you some value one thing that might have
hit mr. radar that I want to get in here
I think a bunch of you saw it but I'm
seeing huge results some of the fastest
feedback I've ever seen is around this
dollar 80 strategy 90 posts on Instagram
leaving your two cents becoming part of
the come up community for growth and
content super fascinating if you don't
know what I'm talking about let's link
it down below babban I'm sure we post it
on Facebook and YouTube by now this your
dollar eighty strategy is incredible one
of the biggest things that so many of
you miss is everybody talks about
content right what content want content
what content nobody's talking about
community you know context of the
content matters but community the three
C's right like content of course we all
talk about it context which is the thing
that I think I've been teaching you
which is what kind of creative and what
platform but community something I wrote
in thank you economy in 2011 it's just
like super duper duper hey man how are
you nice to meet you yeah you're in it
out you're in it bro you're in it
community community really really really
really matters and this dollar eighty
strategy is one of the more unique
clever ways that I've come up with it
have you seen it yet babban
I'm pumped about it check it double down
on a dollar eighty [ __ ] go 360 well this
is gonna be a funnier kind of episode
let's settle this once and for all you
know babban d-roc kyle justin iris right
those are the five have really done it
once you headed up a scene two scenes
that are six seconds each that's 12
times 5 60 seconds to scenes this is
your now you've got to be fair because
it's you Babbitt in it so you have to be
fair or don't - scene six seconds each
from all five and in the comments
section vote for your favorite
production editor predator producer the
wreck
dailyvee just started World War 3 I mean
look d-roc has a disproportionate
Vantage for being around for a long time
you have this whole kind of like
underbelly cult following iris has won
over a lot of hearts she's really scoped
just some disadvantage for being around
being gone for a little while
hi how are you my leave that there
my I couldn't print my ticket cuz there
was some adjustments just and
disadvantage it for being away for so
long and Kyle's new but as a crazy
mustache chopped it up give us answers
so it's early Monday morning and I've
been wanting to make a Monday morning
video for a long time but finally d-roc
we're doing it so real quick this is
just a rant its skits Congrats stern
[ __ ] debt I think you need to be more
Better Homes and garden and less QVC got
it you're welcome you're welcome
take care thank you thank you so much
man I appreciate that
how are you nice to meet you man babban
here is all bent out of shape he just
said today is rough to be very frank
with you vaynernation i don't give a big
night for d-roc ivan [ __ ] up the case
with sneakers and bab and literally
forgot the sneakers at the office this
morning I don't know if we caught it
iris I don't think so I told Tyler like
bringing the [ __ ] sneakers to the
shoot for the shoot of the [ __ ]
sneakers Stabbin it would have been good
if you figured it out 19 minutes ago
instead of and I mean that so I think
the real reason I give away my content
for free I engage with all of you I
answer I give love I think the biggest
reason I do that is cuz I don't need
your help or money to accomplish my
goals I think it's the ultimate leverage
to be able to give more and always give
more and always give more and learn how
to take not at the expense of the people
you've giving and I'm starting to find a
little clarity starting to understand
why this thing is so hard this game of
entrepreneurship [ __ ] this game of life
it's because the real answer is really
found when you're pulling from opposite
directions
send your lane saying why why why am I
so blessed
why is all this good stuff happening
I'm a contradiction you know I knew that
what I was doing in business what I was
doing in friendship what I was doing in
parenting like that was all on point but
in the back of my mind I knew that my
health wasn't there right but the way I
was rolling I should have looked a
thousand times worse than I looked back
then right like my weight and just my
body structure my natural DNA kept it in
check enough that I wasn't 400 pounds
because there was no good eating habits
there was no zero
I mean basically there was zero exercise
zero to the time I was 38 and a half
when I did this so it's on the back of
my mind since I turned 30
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]